Musik Unterm Gag-Feuerwerk bleibt nicht viel da, ausser Lacher und Schmerz.
Nach einer Zeit merke ich jedoch dann, diese Raketen greifen mich nicht an. Sie bringen Spass auf Knopfdruck, wenn ich will Es sind Stefan, der T nur mit das Podcast-Ufo beschäftigt. Wir hören uns heute nochmal alle Folgen an, holen unsere besten Momente raus und da wird bestimmt noch das ein oder andere dabei sein. Von Stefan Tiberius Tietze, er ist anwesend. Captain, ja, Captain Stefan Tietze, denn, ich hab's geschafft, Prüfung ist bestanden, Herzlichen Glückwunsch! Die praktische Prüfung ist auch bestanden. Segel auf. Segel auf, Mast runter. Jetzt wird in See gestochen, dann doch mit dem Bug oder Heck voraus, je nachdem. Ich habe bravoureus meine praktische Prüfung bestanden. Es waren 40 Grad mitten auf dem Rhein. Ich glaube, der Prüfer wollte einfach nur zum Länderspiel. Ist egal, war ein bisschen merkwürdig die Prüfung, aber wir haben es hingekriegt. Stefan, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe nicht an dich geglaubt. Ab der ersten Sekunde dachte ich, du scheiterst, du lässt dieses Projekt wie so viele nebenbei liegen. Auf dem Küchentisch bleibt das mal liegen. Und ich wollte es nicht laut aussprechen, dass du versagen wirst, dass du scheitern wirst, dass all deine Mühe umsonst sein wird. Ich spiele jetzt hier mal ein, wie du es laut gesagt hast. Und deswegen freut es mich natürlich umso mehr, dass ich Unrecht behalten habe und du tatsächlich an ein Ziel gekommen bist. Herzlichen Glückwunsch an seinem Ziel ist vielleicht auch bald Nick, von dem dieses fantastische Intro stand, der als Zyniker mit seinem Künstlernamen auf den digitalen Bühnen dieser Stadt und dieses Landes unterwegs ist. Von daher vielen Dank an Nick für dieses sehr zeitgemässige Intro. Zeitgemäss und auch ein bisschen melancholisch. Und ich finde es total gut, dass man, wenn man unsere Intros hören würde, wenn man sagt, okay, da ist ein Podcast, wir verraten noch nicht welcher, hat seine Community aufgerufen, Intros reinzuschicken. Ja. Und dann hört man sich diese Intros an, man würde nicht denken, wir machen Comedy. Das stimmt. Ich finde es aber auch gut, weil ich will nicht diese Tröten haben und Clownsgeräusche und nein, aber ich frage mich, was machen wir denn auch falsch, dass die meisten unserer Intros sind wahnsinnig melancholisch. Ja, entweder sind wir ein sehr vielschichtiger Podcast oder die Leute nehmen einfach die Songs, die sie ohnehin schon produziert haben, machen mit einer Computerstimme noch das Podcast-Ufo drüber und schicken sie uns. Also eins von beidem kann sein. Eins von beidem. Mir gefällt das erste ganz gut. Ich finde das Wort Schmerz kam mir zu häufig schon im Intro vor. Schmerz, Leid, ja. Ja, Schmerz und Leid. Elend. Elend, Kummer, Zwang, Darb, Darben, Fürchternis, Fürchternis, Finsternis, Darbtum, Siechtum, Müssiggang, all das sind in diesem Podcast enthalten. Ich würde dir zum ersten Mal zuhören nach unserem großen Artikel, der vielleicht diese Woche erschienen ist in der Taz oder Faz. Taz oder Faz. Taz oder Faz oder Faz oder Faz das Haustiermagazin in einem dieser drei Landesmedien werden wir erscheinen. Und es ist gar nicht so schwer, ein Interview in der Tatze zu bekommen, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Wir waren da kurz da. Wir waren ein bisschen irritiert, wie monothematisch die Fragen dann doch waren. Ja, das stimmt. Und nach, was habt ihr beide denn für ein Haustier? Ne, keins. Die Stille war auch ein bisschen unerträglich, da sind auch dann drei Seiten einfach komplett leer. Ich habe ja gesagt, ich bin mal auf ein Pferd geritten, da waren die ganz schockiert und dann meinten die so, Pferde haben keine Tatzen. Bitte nicht erwähnen. Huftiere. Bitte keine. Huftiere. Hufe sind Form von Tatzen. Dann geht doch zur Huf nebenan, die ist direkt nebenan. Die Hufgut, alles gut. Es gibt ja unfassbar viele Magazine. Ist ja unglaublich. Warum werden Tiere auf die Form ihrer Füsse reduziert? Ist es auch so eine Form von Rassismus, zu sagen, die Paarhufe, warum werde ich auf meine Hufe reduziert? Ja, vor allem, Pferde leisten viel. Wir sind Pferden, ich finde, Pferde haben mehr Rechte verdient, als nur als Huftiere bezeichnet zu werden. Welche Rechte genau hast du im Sinn für Pferde? Naja, ein langes Leben mit mehr Heu für die Pferde. Mehr Heu für die Pferde. Gut, aber gib dafür euer Wahlrecht ab. Ich soll mein Wahlrecht abgeben? Du gibst dein Wahlrecht ab, damit Pferde mehr Heu bekommen. Kann ich denn noch davor wählen, dass Pferde mehr Heu bekommen? Nein. Ich fände es, wenn Demokratie auf persönlicher Basis funktionieren würde. Du gehst persönlich zur Kanzlerin und diskutierst aus und sagst, sie hat gern ein bisschen mehr Geld. Okay, dafür wählst du nie wieder. Ich hatte auch die Idee, man sollte mehr Klassen einführen. Dieses Zwei-Klassen-System ist lame. Lame, mehr Klassen. Ich will Magier, Krieger, der Klassenkampf muss wieder spannender werden. Und dann aber auch zurückskillen, wenn man sagt, ich bin nicht Magier, will ich nicht mehr sein. Ja, immer nur dieses Bourgeoisie und Proletariat. Nein, ich will Krieger, Jäger, Schurke, ich will all das haben. Und ich würde gerne auf Humor noch mal ein bisschen mehr scannen. Ich dachte neulich, weil jetzt habe ich mich mit dem Prüfungssystem auseinandergesetzt und dachte, kurz habe ich irgendwo eine Spassnachricht in einem Forum für bare Münze genommen. Nämlich, es gibt Noten für die Brutsprüfung. Da dachte ich kurz, wie genial wäre das denn?
Noten für Führerscheine.
So, und jetzt gibt es bestimmte Strassen, zum Beispiel in Grossstädten, wo nur ab zwei plus gefahren werden darf.
Es gibt Noten für Führerscheine.
So, und jetzt sagen natürlich viele, okay, ich hatte eine komische Situation, doof, deswegen habe ich nur eine vier, deswegen darf ich nicht in Köln fahren, ich darf nur in Leverkusen fahren und auch nur drumrum. Und auf einer Autobahn darf ich maximal 120 fahren, kann man dann nicht was machen. Und ich sage ja, ich sage nicht nein, ich sage ja, du kannst dich zu einer Nachprüfung anmelden. Es gibt mündliche Nachprüfungen, es gibt praktische Nachprüfungen, die kosten ein bisschen Geld, aber auch nicht zu viel. Aber du kannst halt an deinen Skills arbeiten. Herr Tietze, kann ich vielleicht in der nächsten Stunde noch ein Referat halten, vielleicht für eine mündliche Note? Ja, was steht denn für ein Thema, Frau Herr Will? Ich dachte vielleicht das Martinskreuz. Das Martinskreuz? Das gibt es nicht mal. Ist das nicht mal Bahnübergängen? Nein, das ist das, ähm, Stefanskreuz. Nee, es gibt das Martinshorn und das Christianskreuz. Nein. Gut, dann nehme ich das Martinshorn. Entschuldigung, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt. Ich würde gerne Referat halb über das Martinshorn. Äh, ja. Ich würde nämlich gerne, ich wohne in Kassel und ich kann momentan mit meiner Note dort nicht Auto fahren. Das stimmt, Kassel ist da sehr streng. Deswegen bräuchte ich bitte noch eine gute mündliche für Martinshorn. Wie sind Sie hierher gekommen? Mit meinem Fahrrad, mit meinem Tandem. Aber ist Ihnen unterwegs aufgefallen, wie geregelt und cool der Verkehr läuft, wie flüssig das alles läuft? Ja, das ist wirklich vorbildlich. Ich habe teilweise überhaupt nicht verstanden, was die Leute gemacht haben, weil das so High-Level-Autofahren ist. Ja, das ist Next-Level-Autofahren. Wie direkt anfahren und losfahren und Hubsignale und ... Und ist nicht cool an Ampeln, dass alle bei Grün exakt gleichzeitig losfahren? Es war herrlich, niemand war am Handy, es war grossartig. Und wissen Sie, wozu Sie führen würden? Schande. Schande. Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich wohne hier, ich bräuchte vielleicht eine gute Note. Ich weiss einiges über Martinshörner, es gibt nämlich ... Du du du du ... das kommt ursprünglich nämlich ... Vielleicht kann ich ... vielleicht doch das Christianskreuz, oder wie heisst ... Jetzt ist es auch ... Ne, wie heisst das nochmal? Es gibt das ... es hat auch einen Vornamen, ne? Stephanskreuz kann auch sein. Ich weiß es gar nicht, aber es ist sehr männlich konnotiert, ne? Warum gibt es nicht das Anita-Kreuz? Die guckt nicht nach, nein, da muss sie jetzt mitleben. Ich muss eine ganze Woche damit leben, dass ich nicht weiß, wie Fussärzte heißen. Podologen. Podologen? Nichts, aber jetzt mit den Podcast-Ärzten, die sich um Stimmbandentzündungen kümmern.
Podkologen.
Zu vielen Podcasten. Podkologen.
Die Podkologen. Okay, Podologen. Das erklärt die vielen Nachrichten, die ich bekommen habe, mit Podologen-Ausrufezeichen, die ich nicht zuordnen konnte, weil ich mal wieder vergessen habe, was wir in der letzten Folge besprochen hatten. Worüber wir gesprochen hatten, ist eine Frage, die mir schon länger auf der Seele brennt, in der Lunge kratzt, auf der Zunge liegt, nämlich die Frage, ist es okay, dass ich Lieferandofahrern oder Fahrern von anderen Lieferdiensten online Trinkgeld gebe? Das Online-Trinkgeld-Thema. Ich habe die Blicke bemerkt. Ich habe Blicke bekommen. Ich habe Blicke bekommen. Ich habe denen kein Geld gegeben. Ich will es auch nicht sagen, Trinkgeld habe ich online gegeben, finde ich unangenehm zu sagen. Warum betont man das so? Tu Gutes und schweig, sagt man doch. Also habe ich den, reisse ich den in die Tüte aus der Hand und habe danach diesen, ich habe euch online Trinkgeld Blick aufge aufgegeben blick aufgesetzt. Ja, du kennst den blick dieses dieses nickende genau der dieser gönnerhafte diese hast doch schon was du willst ich habe dir doch warum bleibst du denn noch hier jetzt nehmt euch mal kurz einen moment und übt mal nicht vom spiegel erst mal nur für euch den ich habe euch online trinkgeld gegeben blick Setz dich mal kurz auf. Es ist ein eigener moderner Blick, es ist ein selbstgefälliger, gönnerhafter Blick. Aber auch mit leichter Unterwirfigkeit. Ja. Dieses leichte, ich habe es schon gemacht, aber ich konnte es nicht. Ja. Und übt den mal für euch und dann geht mal vom Spiegel und guckt euch an, wie albern das aussieht. Das mussten halt die Lieferanten vorher immer bei mir sehen. Ja, ich habe es jetzt jedenfalls, letzte Woche haben wir es ausführlich diskutiert und mir haben sehr viele Menschen geschrieben. Vielen Dank dafür. Zum Beispiel der Dirk, der schreibt, Jo Stefan, Thema Lieferandotrinkgeld, ich bin seit ein paar Monaten bei der Orange Army. Nice, die Orange Army. Okay. Und kann der die Puffo-Frage deshalb beantworten. Das Online-Trinkgeld kommt zwar direkt beim Fahrer an, das hat auch ein Kollege aus der Schweiz,
der beim Lieferando-Pendant in der Schweiz
ist, gesagt, es kommt an,
allerdings erst nachdem der
Auftrag in der Lieferando-Fahrer-App abgeschlossen
wurde. Heißt, sie stehen bei mir
im Treppenhaus, bei mir vor der Tür,
geben mir das Essen,
kriegen kein Trinkgeld, sind sauer,
gehen runter, schließen den Auftrag
in ihrer App ab und sehen dann, ah, doch, gegeben. Ach Gott, das ist ja wirklich ungünstig. Bedeutet, dass in dem Moment an der Tür dein Lieferant noch nicht weiss, ob und wie viel Trinkgeld du gegeben hast. Das führt dazu, dass dein Treppenhaus auch mal schnell eine Beleidigung geflüstert wird. In vielen Fällen unberechtigt. Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es den meisten Fahrern, aber egal, ob online oder cash, es ist in beiden Fällen steuerfrei.
Aber es ist einfach worst of both worlds. Einfach du hast das dumme Gefühl und musst trotzdem noch Trinkgeld geben.
Is worst of worst worse.
Das ist befindlich, kann ich dir sagen, gibt das Trinkgeld am besten direkt.
Das wird sehr selten genutzt, bei uns zumindest, und wird prozentual am Ende auf die Mitarbeiterin verteilt,
so dass du Ende des Monats 2,61sechzig durch die Online-Trinkgeldspenden ausbezahlt bekommst. Also gibt's gern direkt, da freuen sich alle. Moment, es wird gleich auf alle Fahrer gleichzeitig aufgeteilt. Genau, Tim ist in einem anderen Beschäftigungsverhältnis, hat nicht genau spezifiziert, worin ich hoffe, es ist okay, dass ich eine Sprachnachricht mal abgespielt habe. Aber wer so souverän, mal zwischendurch einfach an einem Podcast, den er hört, mit Wind durchsturmt. Mit Wind und Autos nebenbei, wie so eine schöne Sprachnachricht klingen muss. Und dann aber auch so souverän, dass es runterrattert. Ich glaube, die meisten Betriebssysteme haben das mittlerweile auch integriert, dass selbst wenn du zu Hause eine Sprachnachricht aufnimmst, automatisch Autos und Wind hinzugefügt werden. Also wenn man mit diesem Casual, weil natürlich, wenn ich eine Sprachnachricht schicke, ich probe das dreimal, ich buche einen Termin im Tonstudio, sage, ich will, dass das gut abgemischt wird, ich will da ein gutes Tonstudio haben, ich will einen guten Regisseur haben. Brauche, brauche, brauche, brauche. Warum sage ich das so komisch? Okay, Ich höre mir auch dreimal danach nochmal an. Okay, ich komme um zwei.
Okay, ich komme um zwei.
Jetzt klingt es nicht mehr natürlich.
Aber hast du dann auch ...
Okay, ich komme um zwei.
Hast du dann das Gefühl, manchmal überprobt zu haben?
Ich habe das nicht mehr.
Ja, absolut.
Dass ich dann denke, jetzt habe ich es so häufig wiederholt.
Ja, jetzt klingt es nicht mehr authentisch.
Überhaupt nicht.
So würde es niemals sagen.
Ja, okay, ich komme um zwei.
Jetzt klingt es sprecherhaft. Und dann nochmal abmischen, dann nochmal schön durch Audition gejagt, nochmal irgendwie schönen Ton anpassen mit Kontrolle, alles. Und dann Authentizitätsfilter auf hundert Stellen, damit es einigermaßen natürlich klingt wieder. Nee, aber schön vielen Dank für den Hinweis. Er ist auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Thema, aber ungünstig gelöst, dass man das erst nach dem Kundenkontakt mitbekommt, ob man Trinkel gegeben hat oder nicht. Das zeigt mal wieder, dass da menschlich versagt wurde. Also es ist einfach, da wurde halt so eine gesellschaftliche Geflogenheit, die es ja gibt, nämlich man gibt Trinkgeld ja auch quasi als Form, das ist ja ein Austausch und so und erst dann ist es irgendwie abgeschlossen und erst dann sind beide irgendwie auf Augenhöhe einigermaßen und das finde ich total doof, dass es ignoriert wurde, dass quasi jetzt erst beleidigt wird und Leute zu Unrecht mich jetzt hassen, obwohl ich danach das online gegeben habe. Ich habe mich aber jetzt entschieden, es wieder so zu geben. Ja, einfach einen Stapel, zwei Euro-Stücke neben der Tür haben, einfach schön immer dabei. Aber wie generierst du die? Durch Wechselgeld. Wenn ich nach Hause komme, weil ich habe oft sehr viel Wechselgeld, das ist sehr schwer, und dann will ich das ganze Wechselgeld loswerden, alles, was kleiner ist als zwei Euro, kommt in meinen Eimer, zwei Euro Stücke kommen auf den zwei Euro Stapel, und dann habe ich immer genug dabei. Aber du hast gesagt, du reisst die Tüte aus der Hand. Es ist immer so problematisch, weil es gibt ein Restaurant, da bestelle ich gern, aber die Lieferung ist immer kritisch.
Essen ist gut, aber die Lieferung ist immer kritisch. Jeder kennt es. Weil die Tüte hat sich, glaube ich, durchgesetzt. Einfach pack alles in die Tüte, man weiß nicht, was drin ist. Ja, ich bestelle für acht Leute, ich bestelle für zwölf Leute und drei Pferde, ich bestelle zu viel. Ja, okay, so ist es nun mal. Aber dezent in so einer Tüte oder drei wird das halt dann abgegeben und wir sind uns alle im Klaren da, das ist ein bisschen zu viel Gewicht für ein Landlebewesen, aber es ist okay. Aber es gibt diesen einen Lieferdienst, wo ich jetzt bin, der immer kommt mit seiner Wärmebox, macht die Wärmebox auf, wo die einzelnen Teile separat drin sind und ich muss sie einzeln rausnehmen. Oft in diesem sehr heißen, unmenschlich heißen Alu. Ja, da wirklich diese in Alufolie eingewickelten Uranbrennstäbe, die einfach unmenschliche Höllentemperaturen haben. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht, aber was da noch passiert ist, ob die in ihrem Lieferauto einen Fusionsreaktor haben, wo das nochmal richtig schön glühend heiß aufgemacht wird. Und dann musst du da die Sachen einzeln rausnehmen, aufstapeln, da wird erstmal beiden Menschen klar, Moment mal, du hast acht verschiedene Stücke, du hast einmal deine Sashimi, Karimi, Kawemi, Kalemi, Sashimi, Maki, Daki, Maki, Flaki und Sack, alle einzeln dabei, diesen Salat, alles nochmal und dann drei Pötte Erdnusssoße und dann hast du das alles so stablich in der Hand, dann muss noch das Trinkgeld übergeben
werden, furchtbar, absolut grauenvoll,
Leute, nutzt die Tüte.
Ja genau, das ist halt auch schwierig, weil
da habe ich das Gefühl gehabt,
wurde ich ein bisschen
zurechtgewiesen, Leute dachten, ich habe
kein Trinkgeld und dann wird sich
Zeit gelassen, wie dann auf meinem
nackten Unterarm dann diese sehr heißen Alufolien-Schälchen gestapelt werden und man in meinem Gesicht, ich lasse mir nicht anmerken, dass es unmenschlich heiß ist, aber der Typ lässt sich Zeit und dann, ich glaube, das war so die Strafe für auch kein Trinkgeld. Aber dann der Lieferbote, der dann immer kommt, ich glaube, für die ist es ja auch unangenehm mit diesem Trinkgeld, diese Sekunde, dieses gibt es ein Trinkgeld, ja oder nein, und dann umdrehen und gehen. Und was der immer macht, der dreht sich sofort um und geht, der gibt mir das, dreht sich sofort um und geht und ich muss dann immer, ne, Entschuldigung, noch für sie und dann, ah, okay, und dann noch Trinkgeld. Was ist dein Spruch, dein Trinkgeldspruch? Hier noch für sie. Hier noch für sie? Hier noch für sie und dann ah, okay und dann noch Trinkgeld. Was ist dein Spruch? Dein Trinkgeldspruch. Hier noch für sie. Hier noch für sie. Hier noch für sie. Und der hat mir schon 20 Mal geliefert und jedes Mal dreht er sich immer weg, will schon gehen und ich meine Passt du deinen Spruch an? Ich bin nicht so wandlungsfähig. Ich habe einen Trinkgeldspruch. Einen Spruch. Für alle Menschen, die vor dir stehen. Hier noch für sie. Ich sage immer, das ist noch für dich. Ach, du duzt? Ja, ich duzt. Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich sieh's. Alle? Die meisten sind deutlich jünger als wir. Wirklich? Ja, bei mir sind die meisten jünger als... Ich glaub, das kommt drauf an, wo du bestellst. Ich glaub, je nach Kategorie kommen eher ältere oder jüngere Leute. Ich weiss es nicht. Bisschen edgy, aber meine Wohnung ist nicht so leicht zu finden, aber eigentlich schon. Ja, für dich, das sind immer die Leute, die sagen, es ist ganz leicht zu finden, einfach auf dem Hof, denn da in das Kämmerchen, in der 2b, 1u, dann mit dem Aufzug in den Keller und dann durch den langen Gang ins nächste Gebäude laufen und dann im dritten Stock. Alle Menschen, mit denen ich befreundet bin, finden das sofort. Die meisten Lieferando-Fahrer finden es auch sofort, Fahrerinnen. Und ich habe auch schon zum ersten Mal diese Wohnung irgendwann finden müssen. Weil ich habe mir irgendwann diese Wohnung angeschaut, habe ich sie auch sofort gefunden. Es gibt aber so eine graue Masse an Menschen, die diese Wohnung nicht finden. Und ich bin sofort in dem Modus, na gut, Trottel. Ich denke immer sofort, das kann ja nicht wahr sein. Und dann kommt die auch immer an mit so einer Attitude, das ist ja nicht zu finden. Und man denkt aber, nee, ich wohne ja hier und jeden Tag kommen Leute zu mir. Ich bin auf der Seite. Ich bin nicht auf deiner Seite. Ich bin jeden Seite. Ich bin nicht auf deiner Seite. Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als Wohnungen, die man nicht findet. Mach doch einfach, nimm dir einfach mal so eine Kreidekiste und mal mit Kreide rote Pfeile einfach hin. So, das ist einfach immer solide, du weißt, was los ist, mal Pfeile hin, damit jeder weiss, wo es ist. Das ist wirklich das Schlimmste. Ich war schon oft irgendwo Termin, irgendwie Meeting und es ist unmöglich zu finden. Und ich will den Leuten immer sagen,
meine Güte, das kann doch
nicht euer fucking Ernst,
da ich ein komplettes Labyrinth muss.
Sag doch einfach hier,
geh da hin und dann da hoch.
Ich meine, wir lieben alle Schnitzeljagd,
wir lieben alle Schatzjagden.
Gib mir doch einfach eine klare Anleitung.
Sag, geh zur Laterne,
fünf Schritte nach Osten, bis du den Uhu hörst, dann dreh dich drei Sonnen nach rechts, dann 40 Grad nach vorne, gib mir doch sowas, habe ich gerne gemacht. Und dann stehen vor dir zwei Gnome, der eine sagt, der lügt, der eine sagt die Wahrheit und der andere lügt und du musst herausfinden, was der richtige Weg ist. Das sagt dann einen, er sagt links, das sagt dann den anderen, er sagt rechts. Wie kommst du da raus?
Das hat doch bestimmt auch schon irgendeine Late-Night-Show gemacht, oder? Eine Essensbestellung gemacht mit einer ultrakomplexen Wegbeschreibung und wenn der es findet, kriegt er 500 Euro Trinkgeld oder irgendwie sowas. Late-Night-Shows, hört ihr eigentlich zu? Das kann auch diese Bibel-TV-Late-Night-Show machen. Oh, da kam Folge zwei raus!
Echt? Folge zwei, ich habe so gewartet, ich habe mich dabei erwischt, wie ich die Seite jeden Tag gecheckt habe, weil ich weiß nicht, was deren Rhythmus ist, also ganz kurz, Bibel-TV hat eine eigene christliche Late-Night gestartet und als ich das gehört habe, war ich aus dem Häuschen. Ich weiß nur eins, sonntags wird wahrscheinlich nicht gearbeitet. War ich richtig gehypt und dachte mir, schaue ich mir an, ja die war, die erste Folge war ein bisschen holprig, war ein bisschen sehr älter, jugendlich. Ja, muss, erste Folge ist immer, funktioniert nicht. Ich meine, die Christen wissen, dass das Alte Testament ist, Kreuz und Rüben ist, kompletter Crap, das kannst du nicht durchlesen, es wird eigentlich erst gut Apollos oder sowas. Das weiß jeder Christ, von daher hat man auch da Respekt, gibt den erstmal ein paar tausend Jahren, um sich zu etablieren, weiß man einfach. Und die erste Folge war so ein bisschen ja, holprig und dann zweite Folge dachte ich, okay, was macht man und was wir kritisiert haben, mangelnde Selbstironie. Also warum nicht mal ein paar Kindervergewaltigungsgags, ja sowas einbauen. Und jetzt im Stand-up, also am Anfang, wenn die dastehen und ein paar Gags machen, wurde tatsächlich so ein kleiner, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Gag war, aber die haben so gesagt, so von wegen, ja, wir wollen jetzt nicht mehr über Corona reden, weil das Thema nervt oder so und dann, ja, einfach totschweigen, so wie in der Kirche. Und ich mir dachte, oh, hier we go! Kann jetzt natürlich auf so ziemlich alles gedeutet werden, weil in der Kirche wird viel totgeschwiegen, aber fand ich schon mal nicht schlecht. Also vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie uns gehört haben, aber ich glaube, da geht man schon langsam in den richtigen Weg. Leider kein Brennender Busch als Sidekick, nicht die Schlange aus dem Garten Eden als Sidekick, leider nichts davon, nichts dergleichen, kein Eglon Messer in den Wands. Johannes der Täufer war nicht Gast. War nicht Gast, aber an sich, ich finde das tatsächlich ganz charmant, weil Late Nights ja wahnsinnig selbstironisch und zynisch sind und da gibt es keine echten Emotionen und alles wird über sich lustig gemacht. Und bei diesem Bibel-TV-Late-Night, die haben schon so ein bisschen den Anspruch, auch über ernstere Themen zu reden, mit den Gästen, so hey, was hast du durchgemacht, du warst in der Jugend irgendwie magersüchtig und warst dann in der Klinik und jetzt geht es hier besser und so. Und es ist natürlich alles so ein bisschen unter diesem Ich-habe-Gott-gefunden-Ding, aber ich finde das immer, also diese Frage, wie viel echte Emotionen kann Late Night vertragen, total spannend, er hat ja auch eine grosse Diskussion, als Jimmy Kimmel da mal so diesen emotionalen Stand-up gemacht hat, ich glaube, da war seine Tochter im Krankenhaus oder so, und dann war er den Tränen nahe, wo ich immer sage, nee, das ist keine Late Night, Late Night muss drauf, muss Gag, muss Gag, muss ironisch, muss alles, alles, was man kriegen kann, durch die Comedy-Maschine durchwursten. Es gibt Leute, die denken da anders, und deswegen finde ich das ein spannendes Thema, wie viel echte Emotionen verträgt Late-Night, und ich glaube, diese christliche Late-Night könnte da ein neues Kapitel aufschlagen in der Late-Night-Geschichte. Wer weiß, wie wir da in 20 Jahren drüber reden. Mir gefällt der Enthusiasmus über diese neue Late-Night-Show, über die noch zu wenig gesprochen wird. Also da draußen, ich rede immer davon so, als wäre es der neue, habt ihr gesehen, neue Folge und alle immer so, was, nein. Habt ihr eine neue Folge gesehen? Also ich bin dann auch schnell, ist dann meine Welt, die Welt und ich vergesse häufig, dass es nicht bei allen Thema war, die Bibel-TV-Late-Night. Ja, das stimmt. Dieser eine Tweet, den man gelesen hat mit drei Likes und sagt, Alter, habt ihr den gelesen? Wie geil war der denn?
Ist die Band eine Orgel? Nein. Nein, die Band ist keine Orgel. Es gibt so einen Sidekick, den DJ, der dann auch so eigene Einspielersegmente hat, die ich nicht ganz verstehe, ehrlich gesagt. DJs? Leider nichts in dieser Richtung, keine Gags in der Richtung, was ich sehr schade finde, aber mal schauen, vielleicht entwickelt sich das noch. Ich finde geil, wenn man so viele G viele Gäste mal rein, dass man vorne eigentlich, wenn man ein Stand-Up macht, muss man dann immer auf so eine Markierung gehen. Ich finde gut, wenn dann genau die Markierung ist, nicht von unten, so ein Stern oder so, beim Niemagazin war es immer so ein Hexagon. Wenn es einfach von oben so ein Heiligenschein ist, unter dem er sich stellen muss, der das Stand-Up macht. Allein das Thema Heiligenscheine kann man so viel drum machen. Jesus im Jugend, allein vor allem
Jesus die Jugendjahre. Das ist so ein Ding,
wo auch, finde ich, noch viel fehlt, weil
in der Bibel hast du ja die Geburt, Kapitel,
Weise, Geburt, Gästeliste, wer kommt
da, was schenken die? Und dann
ist er ein relativ harter Cut
und dann ist er um die 30 und macht da seinen
Jesus-Kram, mitläuft über Moonwalk,
übers Wasser. Ja, aber seine ganze, seine
Hot-Teenager-Jahre mit Maria Magdalena. Ja, ich will die Teenager-Jahre. Ich will die ungeschwärzte Wahrheit. Ja, ich will die Teenager-Jahre, ich will, wie er im Zeltlager ist, wie er versucht, mit anderen Kindern zu bonden und Jugendlichen. Ist im Zeltlager, sie schleichen sich aus dem Zelt, seinen Heiligenschein erleuchtet, grell alles. Du kannst nicht mitkommen, Jesus. Mach den aus. Ja, was, ich kann den nicht ausmachen. Dann mach mir Wein. Ja, ich kann den nicht ausmachen. Dann mach mir Wein nochmal. Nein, wir sind zu jung beim Einen. Dann kannst du auch... Jesus! Kannst du auch Weed? Kannst du auch Gras Weed machen? Allein da kannst du Staffelnweise Sachen drüber machen. Erster Schultag mit Jesus, Ferienlager, die erste Liebe, ganz, ganz große. Schwimmunterricht mit Jesus, das finde ich auch gut. Und er kann nicht entscheiden, oh, ich bin auch gut, wenn er gezwungen wird, vom Drei-Meter-Brett zu schwimmen. Alle müssen vom Drei-Meter-Brett, aber er kann über Wasser gehen und hat Angst, dass er aufs Wasser aufschlägt. Hat er einfach gebrochene Beine, voll eingegipst. Ich hab's euch gesagt, aber alle müssen vom Drei-Meter-Brett springen. Nur weil du der Heiland bist, der Sohn Gottes, kriegst du jetzt hier keine Sonderbehandlung, Jesus. Dein Elternsprechtag, will ja auch gut, Elternsprechtag, Jesus in der Schule, Elternsprechtag mit Gott und Maria. Gott kommt zu spät, Maria genervt im Büro vom Rektor. Komm gleich. Wollen wir schon mal anfangen? Das ist so eine schwierige. Ich finde es gut, wenn der Vater auch hier wäre. Da hat man ja einiges. Aber haben Sie denn eine vernünftige Ehe? Also wohnt Jesus Christus in einem guten Haushalt? Können wir vielleicht über unseren Sohn reden? Ich glaube, das ist gerade gar nicht so wichtig, wie es in der Ehe läuft. Naja, er erwähnt manchmal, dass die Situation zu Hause nicht so ganz geklärt ist. Ja, lassen wir uns vielleicht thematisch bei unserem Sohn bleiben. Ja, ich glaube, da gibt es genug zu bereden. Ich glaube nur, dass es mir auch helfen würde, pädagogisch ein bisschen mehr über den Haushalt zu wissen. Wo wohnt Jesus, wo kommt er her? Da können Sie ja seinen Vater fragen. Der ist ja nicht hier. Ach, wirklich? Hallo! Ich bin überall ...
Auch so ein Ding, auch so ein Ding, auch so ein Ding.
Weil ich hab gerade Making-of The Conjuring geschaut.
Frag mich, warum ...
Jetzt ist das ein Horrorfilm, oder?
Genau, eine riesige Reihe, seit den 70ern gibt's ja schon diese Reihe,
jetzt mit James Wan wieder auferlebt worden.
Und dann haben die das Making-of gezeigt, wo erst mal ein Priester kam,
ein echter Priester, um das Set zu sagen. Um halt keine Ahnung, der hat dann das Set geweiht und die ganze Crew gesegnet. Und dann hat er gesagt, in so einem abgesetzten O-Ton hat er dann gesagt, dass die Dämonen, der Kosmos, weiss ja nicht, dass es gerade hier Fiktion ein fiktionales Projekt ist. Und wenn dann die Schauspieler Dämonen beschwören, by the way, die Texte, die ein Autor sich ausgedacht hat, dann wissen die Dämonen nicht, dass es nur eine Übung ist. Diese übernatürlichen, jahrtausendalte Dämonenwesen, die wissen nicht, dass das nur ein Film ist. Die wissen nicht, dass das nur ein Film ist. Was ist das denn für eine geile Aussage? Na ja, es kann schon sein, wenn schon sein, wenn da jetzt, wir so sagen, wir beschwören Dämonen, dass dann halt der Zorn Gottes auf uns herunterbricht und eine Sinnflut kommt, weil Gott weiß nicht, dass es nur Spaß ist. Na klar, natürlich. Und dann hat er das ganze Team gesegnet und war dann auch ein bisschen besorgt bei manchen Szenen, weil die halt dann Dämonen beschwören und so. Und er kann damit nicht so richtig, hat er erst mal das ganze Team gesegnet. Das fand ich nicht so schlecht. Ach, wie sehr vor du stirbst, bist einer im Forte Petro und sagt, na ja, du komm jetzt nicht in den Himmel, sie haben ja Dämonen beschwört. Wie, meinen Sie für den Film damals? Ich bin Steven Spielberg. Na, sie haben ja Dämonen beschwört. Das war ein Film, es war ein fiktionales Projekt, das ist ausgedacht. Wie Film? Was heißt Film? Sie haben diesen Palast hier, alles errichtet, die sind quasi allmächtig. Naja, lass uns darüber nicht sprechen. Gott ist allmächtig. Ja, ich bin, ja, deshalb, ich bin halt so der... Schon mächtig, aber... Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ja. Sie wissen nicht, was ein Film ist? Sie wissen nicht, was ein Film ist? Also ich habe natürlich schon mal davon gehört, aber Sie kennen Theater. Sie kennen ausgedachte Geschichten, Sie kennen Geschichten. Die Bibel. Na gut, das ist ein doofes Beispiel, weil die ja offensichtlich war, aber... Nee, aber sie haben, also sie haben Dämonen beschwört, sie haben da, sie haben da den aufgeschnitten, sie haben den Arm abgeschnitten. Das war ein Special-Effekt, das ist nie passiert, das war ein Gubiarm, mit so einem Ketchup-Drücker da drin, damit es rausspritzt. Und die meisten Sachen waren am Ende CGI eingefügt. Ja, aber das darf man nicht. Wo steht das? Zeigen Sie mir die Stelle in der Bibel, wo steht, dass CGI-Special-Effekts nicht erlaubt sind. Man darf nicht so tun. Leider ist meine Schicht jetzt auch vorbei. Und setz nicht einfach da hin, ich komme nochmal. In den Wartebereich. Aber das ist eigentlich, da ist so viel möglich. Da ist so viel möglich. Aber das ist schon eine gute Aussage, die Dämonen wissen nicht, dass es nur gespielt ist. Genau, erst mal, und die Dämonen denken auch so, was ein arrogantes Arschloch. Die Dämonen so, sorry, aber wir wissen ganz genau, was Film ist. Wir kennen, mein Lieblingsfilm ist Der Exorcist. Ja, aber ich kann es ganz gerne The Conjuring 2, da braucht es ehrlich gesagt nicht noch einen dritten Teil, der zweite war schon ziemlich lame.
Er war schon ein bisschen lame und der dritte Akt hat nicht funktioniert. Ehrlich gesagt, so klingen Dämonen für mich. Das ist für mich die Hölle. Menschen, die so sprechen, die ganze Zeit. Und du musst auch so sprechen. Und deine Stimme tut richtig weh, die ganze Zeit. Du musst den ganzen Tag über Horrorfilme diskutieren und welcher Film der beste war. Ja, ich fand schon Cabin in the Woods irgendwie klar, diese Meta-Ebene ist natürlich schon, da muss man sich nicht mit anfreunden können, aber die Effekte waren gut. Und dieser Weirdo-Pfarrer, der dann da ans Set kam, der hat dann gesagt, lieber Gott, bitte komm zu uns, bitte komm zu uns, bitte komm zu uns. Und ich habe mich gefragt, Moment, aber es heißt doch, Gott ist überall, Gott ist allmächtig, Gott ist immer um uns herum, wo sich auch nicht so richtig geeinigt wurde, mal jetzt auf eine klare Linie. Da wünsche ich mir auch mal so ein bisschen, weil die Bibel ist schon voller Widersprüche. Doch, doch, doch, doch, brauchst mich gar nicht so angucken, die Bibel ist voller, voller Widersprüche. Unter anderem, wo ist Gott genau? Ist er jetzt überall, ist er allmächtig, ist er um uns herum? Mein Gott, der ist der brennende Busch, das haben wir doch jetzt geklärt. Wir haben fucking hundert Brainstorming-Sessions abgehalten, wie wir diesen Charakter Gott da irgendwie einführen werden. Du darfst kein Bildnis machen, was das erste Gesetz ist, by the way, Gebot eins, das ist das Allerwichtigste, du darfst kein Bildnis machen. Und wie sollen wir das machen? Es wird auch irgendwie ein bisschen wie so eine Bottle-Episode. Wir haben kein Geld mehr für ein Bildnis. Okay, mach die Regel, man darf kein Bildnis von mir machen. Ja, deswegen ist auch der Elternabend einfach schwierig, weil er einfach so... Das wird er wohl sein. Das wird er wohl sein. Wieder der brennende Busch, ist das sein Ernst? Bim, bim, bim! Rauchmelder. Ach, na okay, kann ich jetzt gehen? Das ist ein Dämon jetzt aber gewesen, wieder? Ne, das war Jesus, der junge Jesus im Stimmbruch. Der junge Jesus im Stimmbruch. Also, wie gesagt, christliche Late Night, da liegt so viel rum, da müsst ihr einfach nur aufsachen. Gut, was ist deine Bewertung der zweiten Folge Late Night Showight-Show, Bibel-TV, Late-Light? Meine Bewertung war Dritter Ring der Hölle, also noch nicht ganz. Drei von fünf Ringen der Hölle? Ich glaube sieben gibt es, oder? Ich weiß es nicht. Von mir gibt es vier von acht apokalyptischen Reitern. Alles klar, ich mache mal acht von zwölf Apostel, war auf jeden Fall zu lieb. Wo waren übrigens die apokalyptischen Reiter im fucking Konfirmationsunterricht, okay? Ja. Wo waren die, ich musste mir Scheiße anhören, langweilige Kackgeschichte und diese ganze Kein und Abel Sache, die immer von den Simpsons in amerikanischer Popkultur zitiert wird, Kein und Abel, die sich umgebracht haben, klingt mega cool, habe ich auch nie gelernt. Nein, wir lernen dann von so eine lame Geschichte. Vor allem, das sind halt alles Übersetzungsfehler. Als ob das Reiter wären. Vor allem, das sind ja das Ende der Zeit, ist ja irgendwie so Krankheit, Krieg, halt einfach so schlimme Dinge. Und halt irgendjemand hat halt das Wort Sünden oder Tragödien halt fälschlicherweise mit Reitern übersetzt und plötzlich, was? Vier Reiter? Was soll das denn bedeuten? Kleines Beispiel, weil wir auch zum Thema Flutige Gräbik mit Übersetzungs zu tun haben. Uns hat jemand geschrieben zum Thema lustige Übersetzungsfails, und zwar war dort die Situation, dass gewisse Formulare hin und her übersetzt werden mussten aus verschiedenen Sprachen in andere Sprachen, und letzten Endes stand dann bei den Formularen auf, welches musste man ankreuzen, welches Geschlecht man hatte, und da stand männlich, weiblich, Taucher. Warum Taucher? Weil divers, also divers, zu Taucher übersetzt wurde. Und so kam raus, männlich, weiblich, Taucher. Was ich schon richtig gut finde, weil wenn da niemand mal nochmal drüber guckt, geht das so raus und die meisten würden Taucher ankreuzen. In meinem tollen Drehbuchprogramm kann ich auch nicht auf Teilen klicken, sondern auf Aktie nur. Share, okay. Wegen Share. Ich kann nur auf, ich muss auf Aktie klicken, wenn ich mit meinen Kollegen teilen will. Aber du fühlst dich ein bisschen wie auf Wall Street, wo du einfach sagst, drauf Aktie. Aktie. The most Wall Street thing. Auf Aktie klicken. Aber wenn das niemand übersetzt hätte, wenn er sagt, ja, in der antiken Zeit gab es drei Geschlechter, männlich, weiblich und Taucher. Das ist schon merkwürdig. Die apokalyptischen Taucher. Die apokalyptischen Taucher. Genau, ist auch gar nicht ganz anders, wenn du sagst, die drei Abnoe-Taucher. Hä? Die apokalyptischen Taucher? Was? Meine Nachbarin jedenfalls, die Übersetzerin, wir hatten ja letzte Woche eure Einsendungen bekommen. Entschuldigung, von Eva kam das übrigens. Fluch der Karibik. Von Eva kam das, diese kleine Übersetzungsfälle. Ja, es kamen noch viele Tipps von euch, viele Vorschläge, wie man diese Jack Sparrow-Geschichte übersetzen kann. Genau, wo wir es bei Jesus gerade hatten mit Kannst du Gras in Marihuana umwandeln. Eine gute Idee fand ich zum Thema, Jack Sparrow soll hingerichtet werden und sagt im englischen Original I'd kill for a stoning, I'd love to be stoned right now, I'd rather be stoned right now, haha, stoned, Marihuana-Konsum, Drogenkonsum, bitte seid da vorsichtig. Das sagt der auch alles. Das ist eine Hinrichtungsmethode. Und jemand hatte die Idee, also ich paraphrasiere, der Henker sagt, wie wollen Sie ins Gras beißen, Pirat? Und dann sagt er, ich würde es jetzt lieber rauchen. Und was in der Richtung. Ich finde nicht einen guten Ansatz, diese Marihuana-Komponente noch zu retten, weil wir hatten viele Ideen für andere Sachen, ich würde mich jetzt gerne abschießen oder sowas in der Richtung. Ich finde gut, dass er versucht hat, originaltreu zu bleiben mit diesem Stoned. Nee, ich nicht, weil es original und scheiße ist. Nee, aber das finde ich sollte man respektieren, dass man hier versucht hat bei Gras zu bleiben. Man sollte Respekt haben vor schlechten Drehbuchautoren, finde ich auch. Nee, dass er sich nicht so leicht macht, einfach sagt was anderes. Ich würde mir jetzt gerne einen anzünden, einen Scheiterhaufen. Den finde ich immer noch nicht schlecht. Wie wärst du mit einem Scheiterhaufen, ich würde mir jetzt gerne einen anzünden? Aber gut, ich bin nicht so sehr in der Drogenwelt verankert. Ich fange an, auch Jack Sparrow als Figur zu hassen. Schaut nicht diese späteren Flut der Griebig-Filme, ihr werdet anfangen, wirklich Jack Sparrow zu hassen. Ja, der erste Film bleibt einfach der fantastischste Film. Ich mag aber noch zwei und drei, aber das sind vielleicht nostalgische Gefühle, sind vielleicht auch keine guten Filme, aber ich mag, der erste Film ist immer noch der beste Film aller Zeiten. Und wir müssen dringend mal Antenne als Thekengold machen. Ja, wir machen Antenne als Thekengold, muss auf jeden Fall sein. Und ja, es schaut man sich immer gerne an und tolle Musik. Und die Musik ist einfach fantastisch. Wobei ich habe gehört, Musikkritiker, aber das können wir auch in der Folge dann ausgiebig besprechen, finden die Musik gar nicht so toll. Bisschen überladen, wenig Kontrapunkt und so weiter. Wenig Kontrapunkt. Das ist so dieses Musikeräquivalent von tektonische Platten, was man immer sagen kann, um klug zu klingen. Ja, es ist ein bisschen wenig Kontrapunkt, oder? Genau. Ja, stimmt schon. Stimmt schon. Ja, ja, es stimmt schon, es ist wirklich ein bisschen wenig Kontrapunkt. Ich habe die beste Idee aller Zeiten gehört. Leider kann ich die nicht richtig crediten jetzt, weil es basiert, also es hat mir eine Freundin erzählt und sie meint, sie hätte das irgendwo in einem Tweet gelesen oder sowas. Das heißt, wir kriegen, ich konnte es nicht mehr rekonstruieren, woher diese fantastische Idee kommt. Aber wir sind ja ein Podcast, wir gucken nach vorne, wir interessieren uns für neue Technologien, wir reden häufig über die Zukunft und wie sie wahrscheinlich sein wird und was für eine Rolle auch Zufallsgeneratoren spielen können. Wir haben über das Magazin Random gesprochen und fanden die Macht von Zufallsgeneratoren.
Wir haben ja die Bestsellerliste gemacht,
automatisch generierte Buchtitel und Autoren.
War ein großer Spaß.
Und jetzt kam die folgende Idee.
Statt einer Fussball-EM mit professionellen Fussballern
lässt man aus jedem Land zufällig ausgewählte elf Leute in einem Turnier gegeneinander anreden. Richtig gut. So, und ich finde das ohne Scheiß fantastisch. Ja. Auch als Show, und da reden wir jetzt wieder direkt zu dir, lieber Guido Kanz. Wir brauchen dich. Wir brauchen dich. Denn was ist das für ein fantastisches, internationales Format, wenn man sagt, Fußball-EM, aber aus jedem Land elf zufällig ausgewählte Menschen, die müssen dann da antreten. Da kann ja ein Kind dabei sein, da kann ja eine Oma dabei sein und so, und als Land hofft man natürlich, dass man seine Elf, man unterstützt seine Elf. Ja, klar. Und dann hofft man natürlich, dass die weit kommen und so. Aber es ist halt random, alle Länder haben die gleichen Chancen und man lernt ja auch über dem Turnier, lernt man ja die einzelnen Characters kennen. Das heißt, man lernt ja auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, man weiß, woher sie kommen, man kennt ihre Geschichten, man rootet für die verschiedenen Menschen und so, es sind Frauen, Männer, alle machen mit. Ich glaube, das Problem bei Fussball ist halt, dass alle nach 20 Minuten nicht mehr können. Ich glaube, allein eine Halbzeit durchzurennen ist nahezu unmöglich für den durchschnittlichen Menschen. Das heißt, nach 20 Minuten viel Seitenstechen, viel Trinkpausen, viel ich setze mich kurz mal hin, viele Rollatoren werden ausgepackt. Und das Problem ist halt, wenn du einen halbwegs sportlichen Teilnehmer hast, dann macht er halt alles fertig. Aber die Chance, dass so bei elf Leuten, aber sagen wir mal, es muss auch gewechselt werden können, wahrscheinlich würde man zwanzig random generierte Menschen auswählen, die Chance. Aber nee, du darfst nicht mehr als die Mannschaft haben, weil sonst wählt der Trainer einfach die besten Elben. Du willst ja auch die Graupen mit drin haben. Du darfst nicht eine Mannschaft haben, also ich weiß nicht, wie groß eine Fußballmannschaft, normalerweise sind es zwanzig, dreissig Leute oder so, aber du musst schon wirklich nur elf. Du brauchst elf und wenn einer nicht mehr kann, dann sitzt er halt da, dann sitzt er halt am Rand.
Oder man sagt, man kann schon wechseln, aber dieser Zufallgenerator wählt auch aus, wer beginnt und so. Keine Ahnung, kann man ja bestimmen. Aber ich finde es total gut, dann muss es einen Trainer geben, finde ich, der kann ja auch random generiert sein. Oh ja, oder halt einen richtig guten Bundesliga-Trainer.
Oder jedes Land hat einen richtig guten Trainer und der trainiert die dann.
Und ich finde auch gut, wenn die dann aufgestellt werden, erstmal die grosse Frage, natürlich wer geht ins Tor. Ist immer die Frage. Und hier finde ich auch spannend, dass man als Land natürlich, was eine gute Durchschnittsgesundheit hat, halt bevorzugt wird. Ja und vor allem auch das Alter, glaube ich, ist auch relevant, wenn du eher ein junges Land bist. Ja, gut, aber das Problem ist ja, die Länder, glaube ich, die eine sehr gute Grundgesundheit haben und eine hohe Lebenserwartung sind auch die Länder mit dem höchsten Durchschnittsalter, oder? Japan, Skandinavien, Deutschland und so, alles eher Länder mit einem sehr alten Durchschnittsalter. Aber es ist eher ein junges Land, dann irgendwie, weiß ich gar nicht, keine Ahnung. Ecuador. Ecuador, ich glaube, jeder durchschnittliche 20-Jährige macht jeden durchschnittlichen 50-Jährigen einfach kaputt, völlig vernichtet. Aber finde ich eine richtig gute Idee. Guido, bitte, wir schalten unseren grossen G-Scheinwerfer auf dem Dach ein, werfen das grosse G in den Nachthimmel. Nee, diese blonde Haare einfach nur. Genau, diese Frisur. Wir brauchen dich, die Welt braucht dich für die Random AM. Habe ich mir auch immer gedacht, wie das nicht zählen soll. Das ist noch viel zu weit weg. Und ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, alles wurde schon nachgebaut. So alle dusseligen Waffen aus Filmen werden schon bei YouTube nachgebaut. Hat da mal jemand eine Batman-Lichtkanone gebaut? Vor allem, du brauchst ja Wolken, oder? Also man schiesst ja die Lampe in Wolken, aber Wolken sehen ja nicht glatt. Das heißt, das Bild ist ja total verzerrt. Das heißt, was ist das? So vier verschiedene Superhelden fragen sich, bin ich gemeint? Ist das ein S, ist das ein B? Ich hab jetzt schon Joy-Hose an, ich will die nicht noch mal raus. Bin ich Squirrel-Man oder Superman? Sagen wir beide jetzt da hin? Wohin? Es ist super nervig. Schreibt mir eine fucking Whatsapp! Schreibt mir eine Whatsapp! Aber haben die auch so eine, weil, woher weißt jetzt, sind da verschiedene Superhelden für Gotham zuständig? Oder für Metropolis? Schätze ich mal, oder? Oder haben die klare Zuständigkeitsgebiete? Weil wer kümmert sich jetzt in Gotham? Wobei, in Gotham bist du wahrscheinlich nur Batman, ne? Ich bin wirklich nicht drin in so viel. Du bist gar nicht drin, ne? Ich bin da gar nicht drin. Ich weiß nur, dass Spider-Man in New York lebt, im echten New York. Und da sind auch andere Leute. Aber ich glaube, die eine Welt hat fiktive Städte, DC und Marvel hat echte Städte, glaube ich. Aber hundertprozentig sicher. Doch, doch, doch, Spider-Man war ja auch in Venedig und Berlin. Ja, genau. Also Spider-Man lebt in einer echten Welt. Ja. Und Batman in Gotham. Das ist, glaube ich, die fiktive Version von New York. Ja. Und Metropol ist wahrscheinlich die fiktive Version von Washington slash New York. Aber ich finde es eine super Idee, wir müssen Guido Kants rufen, wir brauchen den Kants Ruf. Und das Problem ist halt, wie kriegst du es hin, dass die Leute auch wirklich mitmachen? Weil wenn du jetzt wirklich sagst, du hast da irgendwie so einen 60-jährigen Raucher, der halt irgendwie kaum von dem Sofa aufstehen kann, wie kriegst du es hin, dass der nicht einfach sagt, nee, ich will nicht mitmachen? Weil dann musst du ja wieder suchen und so lange suchen, bis jemand mitmachen kann. Also da ist eine Menge Betrugspotential. Es muss eine gewisse Pflicht geben.
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, du kriegst, also der Trainer oder der Promi, sagen wir mal,
jedes Land kriegt einen Promi, halt natürlich, Guido Kant sitzen alle auf der Couch und jeder Land kriegt einen Promi und Deutschland ist halt ein Elton oder so und Elton kriegt
diese elf Namen, diese elf Adressen und dann kannst du erstmal die erste Folge ist, Elton
fährt durch Deutschland und besucht diese elf Namen und klingelt da und sagt, bitte, bitte kein Rentner, bitte kein Rentner, ding dong, bitte kein Rentner, hallo und dann ist er ein achtjähriges Mädchen und denkst dir, vielleicht sogar besser als ein Rentner. Und dann sagst du, hallo, wir wollen Fußball spielen, willst du mitkommen? Weil die haben nur die elf Leute und wenn die nicht wollen, dann stehen die nicht auf dem Platz. Ja, aber das will ich mir schon angucken. Also ein Format, wo Elton achtjährige Mädchen aus ihren Wohnungen lockt, finde ich gut.
Aber das ist... Und wenn die nicht wollen, dann stehen die nicht auf dem Platz. Ja, aber das will ich mir schon angucken. Also ein Format, wo Elton achtjährige Mädchen aus ihren Wohnungen lockt, finde ich gut. Unter dem Vorwand einer Random-Man. Aber moderiert das nicht Guido Kanz? Nein, das finde ich schon. Random, Randem. Ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht, weil am Ende stehen halt auf dem Platz vielleicht nur fünf Leute. Und sagst dir, die anderen sechs wollten nicht kommen. Wir rufen sie jetzt nochmal an. Wollt ihr wirklich, dass Deutschland verliert jetzt gegen die Schweiz? Wer gewinnt? Elf achtjährige kleine Mädchen oder Jungs oder elf siebzigjährige? Und das ist das nächste Format. Das ist schon das nächste Format. Steinalt gegen Blutjung, das neue Format. Wer gewinnt da? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es wirklich nicht. Aber das ist schon eine interessante Möglichkeit. Aber ist Fussball da der richtige Sport dafür? Ich glaube schon. So ein Mannschaftssport, den jeder versteht, ist, glaube ich, nicht schlecht. Ja, also als beliebteste Sportart Europas finde ich ja auch gut. Ich finde ja auch nicht schlecht, verschiedene Nationen zu haben. Ich möchte ja auch das Klassiker Deutschland gegen Frankreich haben, wo die sich dann beleidigen, die nicht verstehen. Ich finde ja auch diesen Kulturaspekt darin nicht so schlecht. Ich finde ja auch gut, dass man sagt, ja okay, Amerika hätte keine Chance, weil da werden wahrscheinlich elf fette Menschen auf dem Feld, die nicht laufen können. Das ist ja auch eine gute Kritik am Land. Aber ich glaube, es liegt auch viel an den Trainern, die gucken, womit können wir arbeiten. Weil beim Football zum Beispiel gibt es ja auch die, die halt einfach schwerer sind, die halt eine gewisse Aufgabe erfüllen, halt da irgendwie die wegzublocken oder keine Ahnung. Und wenn du sagst, hey, bei mir sind alle massiv übergewichtig, kann ich da was draus machen, kann ich das sinnvoll einsetzen? Ich habe hier irgendwie die Lea. Darum ist Fussball der falsche Sportler. Ich habe hier die siebenjährige Lea, die ist halt super schnell, aber die ist vielleicht nicht stark. Du musst ja dann auch ganz andere Formationen spielen und andere Möglichkeiten einsetzen. Lea ist immer ganz rechts, ganz rechts und rennt Wiesel flink nach vorne und kriegt den Ball einmal kurz und passt ihn dann irgendwo hin, den niemand aufhalten kann. Ja, aber wir sind ein Rentner, der hat einen Schuss frei. Danach kennt er das nicht mehr. Genau, die Lebenserwartung gibt noch einen Schuss her. Und die Chance, dass seine Hüfte rausspringt, ist sehr hoch. Das heißt, er hat so Jack Sparrow-mäßig einen Schuss. Ja, so und das muss einmal funktionieren, weil ein 1-0 reicht uns gegen Lettland. Die haben nämlich nur alte Menschen. Ja, und dann einfach mauern. Nee, Lea ist nämlich schnell. Lea flitzt am Rand, und Günther hat einen Schuss frei. Und das ist die Taktik, die Deutschland hat, das ganze Turnier über. Ja, finde ich die gute Idee. Und danach kommt der Physio und rennt Günther wieder ein, und dann hat er für das nächste Spiel wieder einen Schuss frei. Ja, das finde ich eine richtig gute Idee. Lass uns das machen. Wir müssen nur diesen Tweet herausfinden. Das Problem ist halt aber auch nur Datenschutz, oder? Du kannst ja nicht einfach sagen, gib mir mal kurz die Liste aller Adressen von allen Deutschen. Einwohnermeldeamt. Ist das ein Thing? Ja, aber wie kriegen wir EMA an Bord? Es ist doch die EM, EM. Das ist nicht ein datenschutztechnisches Problem. Ich glaube, da gibt es viele Probleme, ehrlich gesagt. Aber vielleicht kriegt man ja eine Lösung hin. Aber es gibt doch ein Telefonbuch, oder? Es gibt doch immer noch Telefonbücher. Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Es wird doch irgendeine Form von digitalem Telefonbuch geben. Und dann machst du da einfach random Adressen. Und dann halt in Häusern, in denen mehr als eine Person lebt, würfelst du aus. Und dann sitzt du am Tisch und so einer vierköpfigen Familie wird nochmal ausgewürfelt mit einem W4. Kann er hinten machen. Mit einem W4, ja. Das ist ja kein Problem, das kriegt er hin. Aber ist die Frage nicht, ob man... Mit einem W8 und jeder kriegt zwei... Aber braucht man nicht so einen Spotify-Zufallsgenerator, weißt du, was ich meine? So einer, der so leicht eine Tendenz mitbekommen hat. Weil Spotify ist ja nicht nur, spielt Musik in Playlists oder wenn du auf Shuffle klickst, nicht wirklich random ab. Wirklich? Spotify hat entdeckt, ich glaube Apple war das sogar, dass der Shuffle-Mode ist nicht ganz zufällig. Weil es würde zu häufig auch mal die gleiche Bände nacheinander kommen, etc. Der gleiche Song, was auch immer. Deswegen hat, ich glaube sogar, Steve Jobs gesagt, nee, der Zufallsgenerator ist nicht wirklich zufällig, der mixt ein bisschen mehr durch als eigentlich. Man würde nämlich sonst zu oft den gleichen Song oder halt einen ähnlichen Song nacheinander bekommen. Das ist spannend. Damit der Zufallsgenerator wirklich zufällig wirkt, darf er nicht zufällig sein. Weil wenn der Hörer zweimal Green Day in Folge bekommt, sagt er, was das sind für ein dusseliger Zufallsgenerator, ich höre zweimal Green Day. Funktioniert nicht, genau. Das ist spannend. Und das fand ich total clever. Und ich glaube, wir brauchen einen, der auch ein bisschen den Showfaktor mitdenkt. Wir brauchen so einen Steve Jobs Zufallsgenerator, der nochmal sagt ... Alle, die in diesem Verein sind raus. Ja, man will ja die junge Mannschaft gegen die alte Mannschaft, die zu junge gegen die viel zu alte Mannschaft. Man will ja sowas haben. Man will ja die Sportler nicht nur drin haben, man will ja so einen mal drin haben oder sowas. Finde ich spannend. Wir brauchen erstmal die Daten und dann gucken. Ich glaube, international wird es schwierig, wir können es ja auch bundeslandmäßig machen, dass halt dann Bayern antritt gegen Niedersachsen,
vielleicht innerhalb von Deutschland
oder so, weil international ist es halt schwer
aufzuziehen, da jetzt mit der, du musst halt an die
Kameruner Botschaft treten und sagen,
Buongiorno, Buenos Dias,
hättet ihr Bock mitzumachen bei unserer
grossen Random-EM?
Aber finde ich eine gute Idee, finde ich eine gute Idee.
Ich finde die Idee, fantastisch.
Und ich freue mich jetzt schon noch auf das Eröffnungsspiel Deutschland-Dänemark. Ja, 38 zu 1 geht es aus. Und nach 20 Minuten liegen alle keuchend auf dem Boden, der Ball rollt einfach vom Wind getrieben hin und her, nichts passiert. Und Nick promotet seine Band, weil er sich ein T-Shirt angezogen hat. Er hat unter seinem Trikot ein T-Shirt angezogen, was leider in den Regeln nicht explizit ausgeschlossen wurde. Nee, wir haben zu wenige Sachen ausgeschlossen in den Regeln vorher. Ja, da muss man richtig viel ausschließen. Man muss richtig viel ausschließen. Auch natürlich ein wahnsinnig toller Charakter ist der Erfinder des Baseball-Handschuhs. Weil es gab nicht immer Baseball-Handschuhe. Nö. Handschuhe. Es gab einfach Leute, die mit ihren gottgeschaffenen Händen, fünfgliederigen Händen, diese Kanonenkugel Baseball gefangen haben, wodurch der Fänger wahnsinnig wichtig wurde im Team. Wenn du einen guten Fänger hattest, hast du alles gewonnen, einen schlechten Fänger hattest, hast du alles verloren. Jetzt sag aber nicht in den Regeln, war nicht explizit beschrieben. So, es war einfach nicht ausgeschlossen, dass jemand ein Hilfsobjekt hat als Handschuh. Und irgendjemand kam spontan auf die Idee und hat sich kurz vorm Spiel halt irgendwas zusammengeflickt aus einem alten Schuh und irgendwelchen Lederlappen und irgendwas. Und kam dann eines Tages aufs Spielfeld und trug als einziger den Baseballhandschuh und auch die die Referee so blätter blätter blätter ist das erlaubt blätter blätter jetzt wird natürlich nicht ausgeschlossen und der war natürlich super krass und ich denke mir wie wäre es heute wenn bei so einem EM-Spiel jemand aufs Spielfeld kommt mit so einem riesigen Schuh das war der Grund von Roger Federer so lange dann erfolgreich war weil er der erste war mit dem Schläger. Davor wurde Tennis mit den Händen gespielt und dann kam Roger Federer. Wissen viele nicht, ist auch schon mittlerweile sehr lange erfolgreich. Mittlerweile spielen alle mit Schlägern. Er hat sich den ersten Schläger selber gebaut und er hat dann wirklich gesagt, warum denn nicht? Das war seine offizielle Ansage, warum denn nicht, sein Claim, warum denn nicht? Jeder kennt es ja vom Schulhof, wo Tischtennis mit den Händen gespielt wird und derjenige mit dem Schläger halt gewinnt. Ja, und der Erste, der sein Biobuch rausholt und damit spielt und einfach alle dominiert. Mit diesem Französischbuch Découverte oder wie das hieß. Aber ich finde das grossartig, einfach die Vorstellung, dass solche Spiele ja irgendwann auch einfach mal durchgespielt wurden. So viele Spiele existieren ja schon so lange, dass jeder Bullshit schon mal ausprobiert wurde und weggeregelt wurde. Aber eine Zeit lang halt nicht, da konnte man halt so was einfach machen. Und es gab bestimmt Leute, die gesagt haben, ja, ich hab einen grossen Schuh oder so einen Stahlkappenschuh oder so einen Schuh mit einem Presslufthammer drin oder irgendwie sowas und alle so Augenrollen, ach gut, das wird jetzt für ein Spiel legal und danach wird's verboten. So ist ja die Formel 1. Die erfinden dann immer Dinge und die sind abgefahren und danach werden die nach dem Rennen verboten. Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir hinten an unser Auto so 20 Silvesterraketen hängen? Für den Start. Für den Start, weil die geben ja Boost und wenn die explodieren, dann hast du diese ganzen Lichtdinger in der Luft und störst die anderen Fahrer hinter dir. Es ist so ein bisschen wie Mario Kart. Wie so eine Banane. So ein Pilz plus Banane. Denk Pilz an die Ingenieure, die Motoringenieure. Think Pilz plus Banane. Wie wäre das denn für euch? 20 Silvesterraketen hinten. Und so eine Montage, wo man dich so sieht, läuft so ein geiler Soundtrack irgendwie und dann sieht man so, du hast so einen Pilz, hast so einen Flipchart mit einem Pilz
und einen Flipchart mit einer Banane und zeigst du drauf
und alle Mechaniker so
mit so ganz vielen Kalendern mit nackten Frauen
drauf und einfach mit so hämmernden
Bassmusik und einfach so
wir kümmern uns drum.
Erf ich nicht schlecht.
Mercedes zum Beispiel hat das perfektioniert in der Formel 1
mit Quatschideen.
Zum Beispiel haben die, es gibt immer das Problem, alle Formel 1 Autos haben das, Reifen auf Temperatur zu bringen. Ist nicht so einfach unbedingt. Du machst einen Reifenwechsel und Reifen haben erst bei einer gewissen Temperatur den richtigen Grip, den du brauchst, um schnell die Kurven zu fahren. Und die haben sich dann gedacht, okay, wie wäre es denn, wenn unser Lenkrad, wenn man das rein und raus bewegt, also nach hinten und zu sich zieht und nach vorne schiebt, wenn man dadurch quasi den Winkel der Räder zum Boden lenken kann. Das heißt, man lenkt das Lenkrad ganz normal und dann lenkt man halt die Richtung, aber wenn man das Lenkrad zu sich zieht und wegdrückt, dann wird es so über den Boden geschärbt, dass es dann Temperatur aufnimmt.
Und die haben das gemacht und alle anderen Teams so, na shit, mega Idee.
Und alle Teams danach
waren so in den Interviews so super
euphorisch, meinten, so was ist eine krass coole Idee.
Und alle haben es so geliebt, weil
die einfach jedes Rennen mit so einem Shit um die Ecke
kommen. Ja, aber sagt der Fahrer nicht, Leute, ich muss hier
bei 300 kmh schon heilsbrechisch um die Kurve
fahren, ich kann da jetzt nicht hin und her pumpen.
Doch, auf einer Gerade hat er uns hin und her gepumpt und es war super lustig anzusehen und reifende Temperatur, mega. Ich dachte, du sagst schon, ja, wir haben alle das Problem, die Reifen auf Temperatur zu bringen, eine Decke, ein kleines Bett. Gibt's schon, es gibt große Decken, Heizdecken. Im Boxenstopp steht ein Bett und da liegen die vier Reifen drin. Muckelig drin. Muckelig drin, damit die, wenn die aufgeschnallt werden, schon eine gewisse Temperatur. Ja, das ist schon so, seit ein paar Jahren aber. Ja? Ja, die haben so schöne Deckchen. Und die haben den aber auch so Formel-1-Bettwäsche, so mit so Ferrari und Tischmacher. Die haben erstmal ein Formel-1-Auto, in dem sie schlafen. Genau, Formel-1-Bettwäsche. Hat auch niemals mal jemand gehabt, ne, diese Autos aus den Comics, die man kennt. Nur aus Filmen. Es würde mich wirklich interessieren, wenn man mal irgendwo ins Zimmer kommt und dann steht da wirklich so ein Ding drin. Weißt du was, wenn wir noch mal in New York sind, dann will ich mal mit dir richtig creepy so nach New Jersey rausfahren. In der Highschool. In, genau, in so eine Suburb und möchte da mit dir mal in eine Highschool einfach mal rein, was glaube ich schwierig wird, wegen School-Shooting und so, glaube ich dürfen da keine fremden Menschen aufs Feld mal gucken. Aber dann auch, ich will auch einfach mal sehen, wie die Teenager da so leben, ob die so genauso wohnen, wie man das aus den Filmen kennt. Ja, ja. Ich will in so eine Highschool, ich will aber auch in eine Uni und in so Dorm Rooms, so Dorm Rooms, in so Fraternities und sowas. Wir sind die uncoolsten Menschen da. Aber glaubst du nicht, wir kriegen das hin, dass wenn wir sagen, hello, we are two Germans from Germany, we can talk about German media in social media in podcasting, dass wir da so einen kleinen Vortrag bekommen bei so einer High School irgendwie in der Vorstadt von New York. Das kriegt man doch hin. Die haben doch ständig irgendwelche Vorträge dabei von irgendwelchen weirden Leuten. Ja, also ich finde das nicht so schlecht. Aber ich will vor allem einfach mal einbrechen in so ein Vororthaus. Wohnen die wirklich so, weil wenn du dich dann einlädst und so und dann bist du dann da drin, dann haben die ja aufgeräumt und so. Ich will wissen, wie ich das sage. Ich will unvorherum einfach reingehen, einbrechen, das soll nicht vorbereitet sein. Ich denke, das ist auch eine Möglichkeit für die Reiseindustrie, weil Touristen erleben ja normalerweise nicht das normale Leben der Leute, die irgendwo wohnen, sondern die sind dann am Eiffelturm, die sind dann in den Museen, was die normalen Leute nicht machen. Du bräuchst eigentlich eine Stadtführung, eine Führung der einfachen Leute, wo du einfach mal in so eine italienische Küche von so einer italienischen Mama reingehst, die halt gerade für die Großfamilie Pasta macht. Wie Pasta will ich? Und da halt einfach da am Tisch sitzt, aber halt einfach normal dabei. Und die kümmern sich auch nicht, dass du dabei bist, die kriegen dann vielleicht Geld von dem Reiseunternehmen oder so. Oder halt einfach mal in so einer Grundschule, in der italienischen Grundschule mal hinten dabei sitzen. Ich will shadowing. Genau. Ich will nicht beachtet werden. Ich existiere nicht. I'm shadowing. Aber so eine Führung für das normale Leben fände ich super spannend. Normalesleben.de Normalesleben.abroad.de Normalesleben.abroad.de Abroad. Abroad.-de. Das fände ich richtig spannend. Das würden bestimmt auch Leute machen. So einen Tag, oder vielleicht kriegst du so eine Art grossen Bruder, den du begleitest. Ich wünsche dir einen grossen Bruder. Ja? Ja, ohne Scheiß. Ich habe mal angefangen, The Last of Us zu spielen auf der Playstation. Und dann hat man am Anfang so eine Szene, da ist man quasi das Tutorial, ist halt in der Story eingeflochten, wie der grosse Bruder einem zeigt, wie man über Dächer springt und so und dann ist man irgendwie so im Waisenhaus und da kommt der Bruder einen besuchen und dann fliegt man mit dem zusammen aus dem Waisenhaus und rennt über die Stadt und dann, kleiner Spoiler-Alert, passiert aber in den ersten zehn Minuten des Spiels, stirbt dann der Bruder später und unscheidlich war noch nie in meinem Leben so fertig, weil ich war so glücklich bei der Flucht aus dem Waisenhaus, habe gemerkt, was für ein tiefer Wunsch in mir ist, einen grossen Bruder zu haben. Wie so schön. Was kommt denn da die Serie The Last of Us, lange schon die Serienrechte Film und zwar von Craig Mason. Mit Tom Holland? Mit Tom Holland von Craig Mason. Nee, das Uncharted. Vielleicht rede ich auch von Uncharted. Nee, also ich weiss, dass The Last of Us, glaube ich, als Serie in den Händen von Craig Mason liegt. Falls ihr nicht wisst, wer Craig Mason ist, Tschernobyl. Falls ihr nicht wisst, was Tschernobyl ist. Ukraine, bumm, ganz viel Atom-Kram, ganz viel kaputt. Nee, ich dachte, jetzt kommt der Script-Nodes-Podcast, aber erklär ruhig die Ukraine weiter. Es gibt auch einen Tschernobyl-Podcast, wo zu jeder Folge, also falls ihr die Serie Tschernobyl mochtet oder vielleicht noch mögen werdet, dann könnt ihr euch ehren auf den Podcast dazu anhören. Zu jeder Folge eine Stunde Podcast mit dem Creator und Writer, super gute Ideen. Ja, aber jetzt wird es langsam Meta. Ich finde gut, wenn es zu jeder Podcast-Urfe-Folge auch einen Podcast gibt. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Zu jeder Folge nochmal eine Begleitfolge. Nochmal eine Begleitfolge, aber auch von uns. Wo wir die Folge hören und dann kommentieren. Wollen wir mal eine Audiokommentarfolge zu Folge 12 machen? Uff, oh Gott. Okay, 14, 14. Oh Gott. Aber wir machen eine Audiokommentarfolge. Immer wenn ich höre, wenn jemand ah, ich fange von vorne an mit dem Podcast, ich mir nein, warum das denn? Es war nicht gut, es wird besser. Warum das denn? Du willst ja auch nicht, wenn du einen Menschen kennenlernst, sagen, ich will dich mit zwölf kennenlernen. Du willst doch die ganze Bullshit, die die falsch gemacht haben, nicht nochmal durchleben. Du denkst dir, gut, dass wir uns jetzt treffen. Hätte ich dich mit vierzehn getroffen, wärst du unerträglich gewesen. Wir haben ja auch oft gesagt, es gibt Phasen in unserem Leben, wo wir uns beide gehasst hätten. Da hätten wir nicht mit einem Hass gemacht. Ja, definitiv. Ja, das war jetzt ein bisschen zu laut. Ja, definitiv. Aber ich habe ja zwei große Brüder, ist super, große Brüder zu haben ist super. Aber du brauchst nicht zwei, das ist nicht zu viel. Doch, zwei ist super, weil einerseits sind die Eltern ultra entspannt. Wie alt sind die denn? Sind die viel älter als du? Das ist ja faden. Private Frage. Sechs und acht Jahre älter, glaube ich, aber alter bin ich mir immer ganz unsicher. Und die Eltern sind super entspannt, weil die sagen, ja, wir hatten schon zwei, das passt schon, bei dem ersten wird noch alles verboten, du darfst, musst da ins Bett gehen, du darfst das nicht machen und dann merken die, ach, so ein Kind hält schon viel aus, das geht nicht kaputt so und das dritte Kind ist dann, ja, die Blutlinie ist gesichert, kannst machen, was du willst und du kannst halt immer so bei deinen Brüdern Playstation spielen oder sowas in der Richtung, was halt auch cool ist, so die ganzen Erwachsenen Spiele. Ich habe mal heimlich Playstation gespielt bei meinem Bruder und der hatte da gar keinen Bock drauf, dass ich immer in sein Zimmer gehe. Und eines Tages hat er gesagt, er nimmt zu einem so einen Adapter teil, er nimmt da mal mit zu sich in die Berufsschule oder sowas, damit man nicht Playstation spielen kann. Und er hat mir davor verboten, Playstation zu spielen, hat diesen Adapter mitgenommen und ich schleiche mich mich in sein Zimmer, wir Playstation spielen, es geht nicht. Und abends kommt er zurück und ich sage, du sag mal, irgendwas funktioniert bei deiner Playstation nicht. Und er war so, hast du etwa gespielt? Ich so, eigentlich nicht, ich wollte nur kurz was gucken, einfach so. Und er denkt so, okay, er war nicht so schlau, nicht so ein schlauer Playstation-Erschleicher. Und ich glaube, da war er sehr enttäuscht. Mir geht das Herz auf von diesen Geschichten. Ich wünschte mir, ich hätte einen großen Bruder. Und jetzt frage ich mich tiefenpsychologisch, was dahintersteckt, diesen Wunsch. Keine Ahnung, so ein bisschen ein Guide fürs Leben. Jemand, der mir zeigt, in welche Richtung es geht. Ja, also meine Brüder haben mir viele Lektionen mitgeteilt. Ich erinnere mich noch an eine ganz konkrete, habe ich wahrscheinlich schon mal erzählt, dass der größte Bruder mir eines Tages gesagt hat, so Florentin, ich bringe dir jetzt was bei, eine Lektion fürs Leben und zwar falschrum lesen.
Naja.
Du wirst jetzt, wir lernen jetzt gemeinsam, wenn man falsch rum liest.
Und dann hat er mir Texte falsch rum hingelegt und hat gesagt, du musst die lesen, weil eines Tages wirst du auf einem Date sein mit einer Frau im Restaurant.
Und wenn es da nur eine Speisekarte gibt, dann gibst du als Gentleman natürlich der Frau die Speisekarte, musst aber selber ja auch noch gucken, welchen Pinocchio-Becher du haben willst und musst die falsch rum lesen können. Bis heute kann ich Texte verkehrter lesen. Kannst du? Mach das gerne mal. Hat er dich verarscht? Ich kam nie in die Situation, dass ich tatsächlich in einem Restaurant, weil erst mal, wie unwahrscheinlich ist es, dass ich auf einem Date bin, dann, dass man in ein Restaurant geht und dann, dass es da nur eine Speise gibt. Und dann, dass aus irgendwelchen Gründen sie nicht bereit ist, sich abzuwechseln mit der Karte, sondern hofftet. Es ist doch für ein Date total gut, wenn es nur eine Speisekarte ist und man, ah, wir gucken zusammen in die Speisekarte, ah, das und das, das kann ja so ein bisschen Gespräch anregen, anstatt dass jeder still in seine eigene Speisekarte guckt, also es ist ja gar nicht so schlecht. Wenn du dann sagst, ah, ich hätte gern die Tagessuppe und sie so sagt, woher weißt du, dass es das gibt und du sagst, ich habe jahrelang trainiert, Falschum zu lesen. Ich kann jahrelang für diese Situation geübt. Also ich weiß nicht, ob mein Bruder mal genau diese Situation erlebt hat und einfach dachte, fuck, kann ich falsch verarschen. Einfach verarschen. Aber bis heute, also versuch das, trainiert das gerne mal, nehmt ein Buch, legt das Falschrumpf vor euch hin und lest einfach mal rückwärts. Kann ja nicht schaden, diese Fähigkeit zu haben. Naja, die einzige Situation, wo ich es anwende, ist, wenn man irgendwie Fußgänger geht und dann gibt es manchmal steht was auf dem Boden. Irgend so Durchfahrtfreiheiten, steht auf dem Boden, nicht am Schild, sondern auf dem Boden und wenn ich da falsch rum rüber laufe, kann ich locker lesen. Okay. Also überhaupt kein Problem. Also wir sind das Podcast-Dufo, der grosse Bruder der Podcasts und wir möchten euch mit auf den Weg geben, lernt es bitte, rückwärts zu lesen. Lernt falsch rum zu lesen, es kann nie schaden, es kann wirklich nie schaden. Ich möchte euch mit auf den Weg geben, lernt es, Musik rückwärts abzuspielen und trotzdem zu wissen, was für ein Song es ist. Denn falls ihr mal in einer Schlag den Raab-artigen Show seid, was in etwa, ich würde fast sogar sagen, die Chance, dass diese Situation vorkommt, ist häufiger, als dass man auf einem Date ist, es gibt nur eine Karte in einem Restaurant, man muss rückwärts lesen.
Also falls ihr in einer schlag den ratartigen, schlag den startigen Show seid, könnt ihr das Spiel Kisum gewinnen.
Versucht auch gerne mal, einfach rückwärts zu laufen.
Normal in eurem Alltag, versucht rückwärts zu laufen, falls ihr mal in einer Situation seid, dass irgendwie starker Wind ist,
der euch entgegenbläst und ihr aber mit den Augenproblemen habt,
so dass ihr rückwärts laufen müsst,
vielleicht auf einem Date, wer weiß, oder alleine,
macht einfach mal alles rückwärts.
Mir gefällt, dass immer Date bezogen ist.
Ja, macht mal einen Guard,
macht mal einen Rückwärtstag,
macht mal einen Guard pro Woche, wo ihr
alles rückwärts macht, Musik rückwärts hören, Bücher rückwärts lesen. Meinst du, das Gehirn kann irgendwann den Switch? Dass wenn du Musik durch die Bank nur noch rückwärts hörst, alle Stimmen rückwärts. Du meinst, wie es das Bild dreht, das man dir in den Kopf sieht? Ja, genau. Dass du es irgendwann einfach verstehst. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob Musik, also Musik rückwärts klingt ja scheusslich. Die einen sagen so, die anderen sagen so. Es kann ja sein, dass du irgendwann dafür Gefallen findest, wenn du wirklich alles, weil Musik ist ja auch viel Gewohnheit eigentlich, was man so kulturell erwartet und als schön empfindet und gelernt bekommt. Vielleicht kriegt man das irgendwann hin. Ja, ob man da irgendwann ins Hütchen bekommt, finde ich echt spannend. Übt es mal und sagt uns das mal. Macht mal verrückte Experimente. Ja, bitte. Und schreibt uns. Kein Freund, keine Freundin in meinem Freundeskreis ist wirklich mal an einem verrückten Experiment dran. Mach das mal eine Weile. Was Beklopptes mal machen. So jeden Abend mal eine Stunde lang Musik rückwärts hören, in der Hoffnung, dass man irgendwann einen Switch macht und man es versteht oder rückwärts sprechen lernt oder sowas. Ich habe niemanden, der immer Quatsch macht. Alle sind vorhersehbar. Geht das auch so? Alle sind vorhersehbar. Lass mal unvorhersehbare Sachen machen. Lass mal komische Sachen machen in der nächsten Woche. Macht mal eine Sache, die komplett unvorhersehbar ist. Macht mal ein Experiment. Hausaufgabe für nächste Woche, macht mal ein Experiment, probiert mal was aus und schreibt uns eure Ergebnisse. Genau. Schickt den an GrosserBruder
at podcast-uvo.fail.
Oder einfach an zentral at podcast-uvo.fail.
Das ist einfach einfacher.
Wir sind sehr gespannt, was ihr lernt in der Zeit.
Geht mal aus euch raus, macht mal was Verrücktes
und vielleicht können wir euch ein paar Lebensbotschaften
uns geben, die wir weitergeben an alle.
Genau. Bis dahin
wünschen wir euch eine
fantastische Woche.
Das waren Captain, Stefan Tietzler und Floatingville.
Oh Gott.
Macht's gut. Wehm ab.
Brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr